ist das die lang erwartete Kriegswende
im Osten der Ukraine wir sehen die
ukrainische Flagge hier auf einem
Hochhaus gehisst in der Stadt balaklia
eine Großstadt in der Region rakiv im
Osten des Landes und wir können mal
runter sehen dieser ukrainische Soldat
steht auf dem was dort die letzten sechs
Monate Wette nämlich die russische
tricolor jetzt abgenommen die Ukrainer
haben gestern hier die Befreiung erklärt
und clia und nicht nur im bei der clear
sondern wir wollen uns das ganze Ansehen
in 50 mehr als 50 Städten und Dörfern in
der Region rakiv weht wieder die
ukrainische Flagge die Offensive
begannen hier bei balaklia Dienstagabend
und hat sich mittlerweile auf dieses
gesamte Gebiet ja ausgeweitet ein Gebiet
größer als das Bundesland Berlin in
Deutschland und wir sehen auch
ukrainische Vorstöße Richtung kubians
das ist die strategische Stadt da oben
und Richtung isium hier im Süden und
easium ist ein weiterer wichtiger Ort
für die russische Invasion der Region
donetski im Süden das heißt wenn es dort
oben weiter geht wenn es hier in tragiv
weitergeht den EU keiner weiter so
vorrücken wie in den letzten drei Tagen
ist es möglich dass ein Großteil der
russischen Front im Osten des Landes
zusammenbricht was ist passiert die
Ukrainer haben ja ein
Überraschungsangriff gestartet am
Dienstagabend sind mit nach
verschiedenen Angaben mit über 10.000
Mann hier vorgerückt in der Mitte der
Regionen also genau zwischen den Fronten
die heiß waren in den letzten Monaten
Donetsk im Süden und Raki im Norden hier
wurde kaum gekämpft hier haben die
Ukrainer ihre Chance gesehen und haben
so völligen Überraschung der russischen
Armee eine Großoffensive gestartet wir
sehen hier Häuserkämpfe und bei der
Klier die hat es noch gegeben einige
Stunden lang bzw ungefähr ein Tag lang
von Dienstag auf Mittwoch und jetzt
sehen wir aber hier wie das Zentrum der
Stadt von ukrainischen Truppen befreit
wurde und nicht nur das Zentrum wir
sehen in Dutzenden Dörfern in kleinen
Städten auch wie die ukrainische Flagge
gehisst wird es ist eine Situation die
ganz ähnlich ist wie im März diesen
Jahres wo einfach die Russen weg waren
sie verschwinden man weiß überhaupt
nicht wo sie sind sie lassen ihr
schweres Material oft zurück und wir
sehen was das für Konsequenzen hat die
Menschen dort kommen nach 6 Monaten
wieder aus ihren Häusern und begrüßen
ihre Befreier mit Tränen in den Augen
wir haben Männer Frauen Kinder die die
ukrainischen Soldaten umarmen wir haben
hier oben ein bisschen was geblirrt das
ist damit die Russen sollten Sie doch
jemals zurückkommen nicht genau sehen
welches Haus das ist aber auch das hier
10 ausstatt aus der Stadt balakia die
Menschen freuen sich die begrüßen die
Ukraine und das sind tatsächlich Szenen
mit denen sie nicht gerechnet hätten mit
denen auch viele sogenannte Experten in
Deutschland nicht gerechnet hätten die
gesagt haben nein die Ukraine kann den
Osten ihres Landes niemals zurückerobern
der ist jetzt fest in russischer Hand
die wo Wirklichkeit ist eine ganz andere
und die Ukraine rückt hier weiter vor
sie rückt vor mit ihren eigenen Waffen
wir sehen hier BTR die vorigen BTR 80
der ukrainischen Armee wir sehen aber
auch hier rechts viele kleine Fahrzeuge
das sind aus Großbritannien gespendete
Fahrzeuge wir haben amerikanische
gepanzerte Mannschaftswagen in den
letzten Tagen gesehen wir haben viele
türkischen Kirby gesehen das sind auch
bewaffnete oder gepanzerte Wagen und
hier sehen wir ein weiteres Dorf womit
der ukrainischen Flagge die Befreier
begrüßt werden was wir auch gesehen
haben wann immerhin zwei deutsche
Panzerhaubitze 2000 die hier benutzt
wurden bei der Offensive mehr aber auch
nicht die deutschen gepanzerten Wagen
gesehen der Ukraine weiter aber sie
versucht hier vorzurücken und so wie es
aktuell aussieht schafft sie es gerade
zumindest in der Region tragiv im
Nordosten der Ukraine hier den Russen
auch auf breiter Front zu vertreiben
[Musik]